Tony DuShane, Writer/Podcaster/Teacher:
“Oh remember remember that guy Tony we
went to high school with who ran around
telling me everyone he’s a novelist? I
saw him scooping ice cream the other day.”
Film Courage: I was watching an old interview with
Jerry Seinfeld (I think it was with Charlie Rose)
and he said something to the effect where
he knew when it was right to eventually
leave the show [Seinfeld] and to stop being a
part of it. He said “If I leave now,” meaning
stop the show “The audience will have this thing
where they will never have to say it was good and
then it started to run out of gas.” How does a
writer know for their project or their scene even
that okay I think I should stop
now because if I keep going
then they're going to be like yeah
this kind of ran out of gas for me?
Tony: It's interesting I mean I've I call it
keeping everyone in the room as long as possible
and I know and and just because we're always
trying to avoid conflict as humans it's hard
sometimes it's even harder to keep our characters
in scene when the conflict is just rocking and
let it let it play out and then so I think what
I think it's more important to let it play out
and then get them out to the next scene of
okay that happened and since that happened
now this is going to happen and how are
they going to get out of that situation
so yeah I think that I feel like that's
that's for scene work but if you know if
I was Seinfeld I would have taken the money
and said what 5 million an episode let's go
10 more seasons you know but I'm not but he's a
stand-up comedian he's not a he's not a you know
at heart so like kind of like like I get that I'm
a novelist at heart so I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
kill the novelist in me to make a tv show work
he's not going to kill the comedian in him to make
next season I guess sure but in the reverse you
you had a screenplay that you were working on
during this lockdown and you wanted to extend it
and do it in novel form so there's been a reverse
too where you realized it sounds like you weren't
done telling the story and you wanted to tell more
yeah I don't know if yeah I it just
it doesn't feel finished and I think
it was just it's it's weird but it was like
speaking to me too much it just kept speaking
to me and I just I kept seeing it this is how it's
showing itself to me I guess which is a very you
know I really don't work in the most efficient
means I should have rewritten the screenplay and
started pushing it around and trying to you
know make it happen but that you know it's I
don't know why I feel like I had to re I have
to kind of re-enter it maybe because I that I
was doing it as I thought oh yeah this would
be a fun story and it started as a fun story
then it meant something to me and I guess when it
meant when it means something to me that's when it
kind of like oh this actually I do need to
tell this this is this is something that
this is something that's personal to me that I
need to tell and that's when that's when I feel
like I'm only part of the process and I have to I
have to do justice to this thing I have to step up
and be the very best I can be to what needs to
be told with these characters and so what what
you know i'll in in heavy rewrites i'll really
know what needs to stay and what needs to go but
I you know I do know the story and I knew I know
where everything goes I just this is when I'm just
just for some odd reason I'm sinking deeper and
deeper and it who knows maybe it's maybe it's
just a book it never becomes a screenplay and that
just everyone laughs at me to the end and they say
well you're in development and I go I know what
that means I'm going to it's going nowhere so
development hell that's what it means what's the
definition of that oh that's well they get the oh
your your book's option oh my god oh my god who's
interested Antonio Banderas he's interested oh
my god and it's just like you know like four four
four there was a four people who called each other
and then Antonio Banderas said oh interesting and
then interesting became like he's interested and
he's interested became like he's clearing his
schedule and he's clearing his schedule became
like he wants to talk to you but not yet so kind
of like a Waiting For Guffman type of thing okay
right right yeah yeah and then it becomes a game
of telephone but you just don't believe anything
you just you just smile and say thank you yes
and then it's it's a miracle anything gets made
if someone's in that situation what's your
advice to them in the situation of getting
optioned yeah just enjoy it I mean it's it's
actually a it's actually a nice ego boost to
have you know maybe someone talked about
you it's like it's nice in a good way yeah
maybe it's it's an ego boost like oh maybe someone
read your book it's just like oh that's sweet I
don't it's not even a relative that's nice so it's
yeah just I just you know there's development hell
but there's also just that kind of a gratitude of
well some people seem to care a little bit and you
know if it goes further great and if it doesn't
be working on someone something else that's it's a
story you need to tell so yeah that's what I was
wondering so especially for someone that maybe
is outside of the industry they're in another
state or country and their work is being optioned
so they're not waiting by the phone like a
like someone waiting for their date to call
who you know like alone you know on a
Saturday night oh Tommy's supposed to call
and Tommy doesn't call so what else should you
be doing you should be writing something new
writing something new being with being with your
people and your writers and your writer friends
who can keep you in check you know it's
yeah I I've done everything wrong it's
I went to my 20-year high school reunion and I
that's before Jesus Jerk was that's right when
I finished my final draft of Jesus Jerk before I
started submitting to agents and at the reunion
I was like I'm a novelist I'm an honest just like
and I it was I was the epitome of the stupid guy
because I wasn't I wrote a novel but no one may
ever see the light of day fortunately I finally
found an agent and a publisher but it was sheer
ignorance on my part to say I'm a novelist before
I have a book published before I have an
agent just because I have a draft done and
it could have been the oh remember remember that
guy Tony we went to high school with who ran
around the the the you know everyone telling me
everyone who's a novelist I saw him scooping ice
cream the other day you know it's and and not
that there's anything wrong with that because
probably most novelists need to publish novelists
need to do that anyway but I just learned to
to to be a little more realistic with
myself and also like kind of I guess
I guess I had a lot of joy at the time and
plus with that scenario being able to write
a novel after coming out of the Jehovah's
Witnesses and doing something that was so
utterly not not frown not just frowned upon to to
be creative and that's that was my whole kind of
life was just crushing my creativity so to be
able it was almost like I come out and go I'm
a creative person so yeah I was Johnny Suede I
was that was that was kind of the buffoon and I'm
i'm going to write a book on one of these days
i'll write a book or an article on everything
I've done wrong in publishing in the film
industry so you don't have to it's just
it'll be probably the largest book I've
written but you went to that that high
school reunion feeling good and you left feeling
good yeah no one tried to burst your bubble no
no that's good well and I also found out that
they all knew I was a Jehovah's Witness I was
trying to hide it at school you know i'd be
like I said I would I would wear suits to school
you know when like I found out that this I found
the specials record the first specials record and
they were mod and they all wore suits and I'm like
I just got to look like that so if I'm looking
like that at school and then I'm walking around
with my bibles and Watch Towers on Saturdays maybe
they'll just think I'm just walking around so I
didn't I thought I was kind of fooling everyone
at school but it turned out they were like oh no
we knew you're a Jehovah's Witness but we always
thought you were cool and I was like there's a lot
of revelations to me that night interesting and do
you still keep in touch with any of those people
I do yeah yes yeah okay and so now they see that
not only did you publish your book but then you
also made the film maybe they probably don't
even care right they get to see that they're
you know i'll I get photos of their grandkids
you know or i'll find out you know one one is
a practitioner and he talked to me about 2020
stuff and what he's you know going on there and
it's just like yeah in the end they might not be
readers and they might not be viewers and that's
that's the beauty of it it doesn't matter I always
come into it now with going you know now I'm
just like I assume no one's read anything or seen
anything I've ever done and if they have then I'm
pleasantly surprised and I say thank you that's
oh it's people will apologize oh my goodness
I haven't watched your film yet I'm like
you don't have to don't worry about it there's
other things in life going on you know there's
so and it's on IMDB you can you can watch it
it's like on Amazon IMDB they have a yeah yeah
yeah it's on Amazon it's on Prime and yeah I don't
know I haven't I think it's someone said it was on
youtube for free so I guess the distributor put
it on there for free which I have no I have no
what do you call it I have no authority on that
on that end of it I just so yeah it's out there
people can watch it sure yeah and there's the dvd
too I I have the dvd I haven't even opened the
wrapper yet it's just like oh okay it's yeah it's
like the bottle of champagne you just want to put
you don't want to you want to open it I don't
even know where it's at in my house I was
when when the giants went to the world series
and in like 2010 and 10 lives to come got like
three Cy Young awards and they asked him
where he put him and he said he thinks
they're in the they he thinks that they're in
his car and I thought that was just so like
dumb at the time and then now it's like
oh no I get that yeah it's because it's
about to work it's not about the it's not about
the end it's about the it's about the middle.
Does loving the act of writing
mean you're actually a writer?